et pour en parler nous retrouvons jean
eric branaa maître de conférences à
l'université paris ii assas
il est aussi un spécialiste des états
unis et auteur de l'ouvragé joe biden la
biographie publiée aux éditions nouveau
monde bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors dites-nous après des jours de
résistance est sous la pression des
parlementaires
donald trump a donc fini par ratifier le
plan de relance économique comment
expliquer ce revirement de la part du
président américain
en réalité la situation était juste
impossible pour donald trump rendez-vous
quand il était en train d'envoyer dans
la pauvreté voire la grande pauvreté 5
millions d'américains en plus d'un
million et demi d'enfants qui en janvier
n'aurait pu rien eu à manger auraient
été renvoyés de leur logement
c'est une situation assez dramatique que
vu les états unis on n'est pas en france
on compare souvent alors on va essayer
de le faire deux secondes en france on a
une sécurité sociale on a des aides
sociales qui nous protège et c'est vrai
que beaucoup d'argent a été débloquée
pour pouvoir protéger l'ensemble des
français qui donc on senti beaucoup
moins cette crise que vit aux etats-unis
frappe très durement aux personnes
emploi en personne assure santé on perd
très vite sans logement parce qu'on ne
peut pas le payer et et tous tous à
cette spirale fait que la dureté était
très forte 9 millions d'américains ont
sombré dans la pauvreté avec cette crise
on parle pas de chiffres de ce genre
dans notre pays c'est vraiment une
situation très différente même si
précise au le aux états unis énormément
d'argent a aussi été dépensés puisque
4500 milliards de dollars ont déjà été
dépensés
c'est le cinquième plan qui est votée
mais c'est vrai cette fois ci ça a pris
beaucoup de temps pour cause de campagne
électorale et donald trump a voulu
opposer les américains aux autres en
expliquant qu'il était désormais
favorable à 2000 $ par personne ce qu'il
n'a jamais évoqué pendant sa campagne
rappelons le mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il
a rechigné donald trump a signé ce plan
de relance alors d'abord parce que joe
biden avait annoncé qu'il allait faire
un grand plan de relance dès qu'ils
prendraient le pouvoir et il avait
exhorté les parlementaires des deux
bords a signé un premier plan qui est
nettement insuffisant
donald trump a raison sur le diagnostic
600 $ ça permet pas de vivre en et vous
quand le loyer moyen aux états unis et à
environ 2 900 $ donc ses 600 dollars ne
permettent pas de couvrir les frais
loyer c'est pour ça qu'il fallait la
sortir d'une mesure qui empêche les
expulsions c'était très important dans
certains comtés à new york ou en
californie le loyer est de 2000 $ en
moyenne on est vraiment très loin du
compte
le lait d'oeufs supplémentaires dont on
n'en parle pas mais en plus c'est 600 $
à 300 $ par semaine
dette supplémentaire pour ceux qui ont
perdu leur emploi mais ils n'ont que ça
pour vivre ce qui est nettement
insuffisant ou encore une fois ne permet
même pas de manger
donc on a vu ces images aussi de file de
voitures qui ne cesse de s'allonger de
gens qui viennent à la soupe populaire
chercher de quoi nourrir leurs enfants
rappelons qu'on en perd deux doigts elle
tout ça est et ce qu'elle montre est
grave
donald trump a cherché à doubler joe
biden à faire mieux que lui alors qu'il
est en fin de mandat et qu'au contraire
il devrait accompagner le mouvement
ce qu'il fait maintenant aux signes
hante mais bien tu as ça il va y avoir
une interruption des aides pour certains
pendant quelques semaines donc il a mis
en difficulté encore plus grande
certains américains
tout ça est fort regrettable car celle
de la basse politique en essayant de
faire croire qu'ils pouvaient faire
mieux alors que le président américain
n'a aucun pouvoir en la matière c'est le
congrès qui laissait alors 900 milliards
de dollars c'est le coût de ce plan de
relance les états unis ont les fonds
nécessaires pour le financer
c'est comme dans les autres pays à la
planche à billets fonctionne de très
fort
la dette augmente plutôt à le dire comme
ça
mais est ce l'urgence actuellement
d'abord la sauvegarde des populations
qui compte c'est la sauvegarde de
l'économie qui est le deuxième la
deuxième question d'importance non je
crois qu'il fallait pas économisé et ce
qu'avait fait le congrès américain au
mois de mars en votant un plan de 3000
milliards de dollars étaient la bonne
réponse qui avait été saluée par
l'ensemble des américains l'ensemble des
forces politiques américaines et à part
un libertarien qui avaient refusé de
voter à ce moment là tout le monde avait
bien compris que c'était une urgence
optimum on peut peut-être se demander
pourquoi les républicains ont mis tant
de mauvaise volonté cette fois ci à
voter ce plan
mise à part la campagne électorale que
j'ai évoquées qui explique bien sûr
cette mauvaise volonté
ça a duré quand même plusieurs mois pour
arriver à cette décision
on aurait pu économiser beaucoup de
pression sur les américains les plus
faibles donc un temps pour économiser un
temps pour dépenser si je vous comprends
bien la dernière question et puis ce
sera le mot de la fin quel regard vous
portez sur les dernières semaines de
donald trump à la tête des états unis
écoutez je le regarde qu'on doit porter
c'est qu'elles sont catastrophiques au
lieu de préserver son héritage qui était
somme toute ce qu'il était et pas
mauvais puisque 50% grosso modo des
américains ont voté pour lui il est en
train de de jouer comme je le disais la
passe politique en essayant de faire
passer son intérêt premier est son
capital politique pour l'avenir
avant l'intérêt du pays c'est pas
glorieux ce qui se passe sur le plan
institutionnel et est une véritable
attentat à la démocratie
et puis là on l'a vu en jouant avec les
eaux et les autres la vie des hommes et
des autres il ne s'est pas grandie en
fin de présidence c'est aussi ce qui va
laissé comme héritage et et c'est fort
dommage et jean eric branaa merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université paris ii
assas et spécialiste des états unis et
auteur de l'ouvragé
joe biden la biographie publiée aux
éditions nouveau monde merci beaucoup